I've officially finished watching The
Last of Us I played the game really
enjoyed it but there's a lot of medical
stuff that we have to talk about this is
not just a live reaction I planned this
out into four categories of things we
have to cover this is gonna be a wild
ride let's get ready to have some fun
guys
all right there's first aid but like I
said this is the worst first aid we got
a couple of scenes here pulled up where
I think there are just glaring examples
of problems starting with the first
episode
sure
we are not sick
okay you're okay
all right so she's breathing fast that
means she's not getting enough oxygen so
the body's responding by increasing the
pulse increasing cardiac output and
trying to increase the breathing rate to
try and get more oxygen
so he's trying to apply pressure this is
the right thing to do in a scenario like
this because she is breathing she does
have an open Airway but in reality
moving a person like this is now
creating more harm than good because
you're not actually helping them in any
way maybe maybe listen to me I gotta get
you up getting her up is only going to
make the bleeding worse faster given how
much blood has come out in this short 30
second interval you can already predict
how much more is going to come out and
as a result you know that she's not
going to make it that's why in a wartime
situation if you were to see an injury
like this it would be about getting the
morphine out not helping the soldier oh
this seed drives me up a wall my guy
doesn't know yet that she's bit and he's
trying to create some sort of ankle
brace for her but he ends up wrapping
her foot like what are you wrapping here
like at least put something stiff on
either side of the ankle so it doesn't
re-roll instead he like double wraps the
foot like it doesn't help anything you
gotta add the stability to the ankle
because when you have an inverted angle
ankle injury what ends up happening is
you can damage the ligaments on the
outside of your ankle usually the
anterior talofibular ligament and as a
result your ankle is very loose and
unstable what I would have done is find
some piece of wood like there's wood
materials all around them and take two
little sticks and put on either side of
the ankle so that the ankle gets extra
stability in fact some of the best
braces that I recommend to my patients
are ones that have like little metal
inserts on the side that literally
prevent your ankle from Rolling side to
side it allows your ankle to have motion
like this plants are flexion and
dorsiflexion but not eversion inversion
boom wooden bat gets hit he pushes the
guy but then he's going to realize
the baseball bat that broke off on the
tree is now in his abdomen potentially
the worst thing you can do is without
thought pull out the object that's been
stabbed into you hey this object is
Jagged so as a result pulling it out is
going to create more damage just like
most knives and other things that get
inserted into you on top of it you don't
know if this putting pressure on a blood
vessel and preventing you from bleeding
out and my guy right there pulls it out
bad move bad move a lot of blood's gonna
come out he's going to pass out and the
reason why he starts passing out quickly
is because due to the loss of blood your
blood pressure drops and you're not
getting enough circulation to your brain
so you lose balance okay she found some
thread
very classic scenario here okay she has
this first of all extremely dirty towel
which is bothering me so much because
she's just festering that wound with
massive bacteria and then she's gonna
suture the wound this is what I find
ridiculous in these shows because
remember he was stabbed in turn finally
so he's bleeding internally her closing
off the wound is only closing off for
the bacteria to be trapped inside of
there and not really stopping any
bleeding because he's bleeding
internally from his intestines his
organs being damaged so she's not
helping him out at all with a situation
like this she's closing a dirty wound
which is something we don't do okay she
got herself some penicillin
and she obviously doesn't know how to
give him the penicillin also this is an
IV dose of penicillin or I am dose of
penicillin so she just kind of ends up
spraying it at him into his wound so
there's basically four ways you can give
a medicine you can give it orally you
can give it topically like skin coverage
you could also give it I am which you
inject it into a large muscle group
think about epipens and then last but
not least you could give it
subcutaneously which is in a superficial
portion of the skin Oh and through an IV
obviously directly into blood like if I
was her and I wasn't sure I would
probably just stab it in his butt and I
know that sounds funny but at least
that's an I am form of the dosage that
you know it's going to get well absorbed
and then travel systemically throughout
the body obviously doing it IV is the
best way but that's kind of hard to ask
in a situation like this Joel is
officially superhuman in this series it
starts with the scene yep classic fight
scene is getting hit this is the worst
place you want to find yourself in a
battle like this because all the other
person's weight is on top of you you put
pressure on these carotid artery series
for just a matter of seconds the person
loses Consciousness in fact here's a
strangulation reference guide from the
city of New York that says only 11
pounds of pressure placed on both
carotid arteries for just 10 seconds is
necessary to cause unconsciousness and
just four pounds of pressure on the
jugular for 10 seconds is necessary to
cause unconsciousness that's because the
jugular vein actually prevents outflow
of blood from the brain and if you block
it you actually have a buildup of blood
in the brain also causing a loss of
consciousness all right so this is the
part where Joel's running away we're
bringing the scene back okay he's
fighting the guy great first of all I
already know he has a bat into him but
the fact that he chokes this guy for
three seconds and then does this weird
motion
this this does not destroy someone's
neck he doesn't even position him in a
unique way he moves his whole body
around and somehow they create a
cracking sound what did he do did he
crack his vertebrae did he crack his
trachea even then the guy would be
laying on the ground choking but instead
it looks like this guy guy just cut off
all circulation this rain he decapitated
him with his ever Mighty grasp on his
neck and obviously office fresh wound
freshly surgically closed by expert Dr
Ellie he's fighting wrestling people my
guys hemoglobin hasn't recovered he's
still anemic walking for patients like
this they'll get short of breath and yet
my guy is wrestling out here like
literally there's a level of
deconditioning that happens after an
infection after a blood loss that you're
not able to do things like this I don't
know any girl oh this is an interesting
scene basically Joel sticks the knife
what looks like through the guy's fever
and or kneecap and or tibia ladies and
gentlemen you cannot just after being
sick and anemic and going into shock
with a knife stabbed through someone's
bone and first of all getting stabbed
into the the quad muscle there's
probably the most painful area to get
stabbed and there's so many nerve fibers
lots of circulation lots of blood loss
but wow the fact that he just went right
through his bone is impossible
stun grenade these types of sun grenades
create such a concussive effect on our
brains that they Shake us up and in a
scenario like this where he was just
injured falling on his wound not being
fully recovered he's not getting up from
this for days it's like getting the
second concussion in sports that I
always tell you about is the worst me
and now he got hit again in the head
he's now waking up for weeks at a time
not without major symptoms at least next
section is called cordyceps is no fun
guys it's my little play on it because
it is a fun guy but it's no fun guys and
just to be clear you you do think
microorganisms pose a threat oh in the
most dire terms fungi seem harmless
enough many species know otherwise
because there are some fungi who seek
not to kill but to control it's actually
true that fungi exists in the millions
in our ecosystems and yet there's only
few of them that have adapted in order
to evade our own immune systems in order
to tolerate the high temperatures that
the scientist is about to talk about
fungal infection of this kind is real
but not in humans true fungi cannot
survive if it's hosts internal
temperature is over 94 degrees and
currently there are no reasons for fungi
to evolve to be able to withstand higher
temperatures but what if that were to
change what if
for instance the world were to get
slightly warmer well now there is reason
to evolve I think it's important to
think through these scenarios as
scientists I wouldn't present this as a
leading threat to our lives because
there are so many things like these
mutations that could happen in certain
scenarios that would be absolutely
devastating to the human race that
talking about it on a daily basis would
just yield so much anxiety that would
ultimately harm us for sure as opposed
to the chance of these things happening
fungi can alter our very Minds fungus
starts to direct the ant's Behavior
telling it where to go what to do like a
puppeteer with a marionette it's also
true that fungi technically met most of
them would be weeded out by our own
internal immune systems but there are
situations where immune systems are
weakened that's actually the majority of
times when fungal infections happen in
humans at least a devastating ones and
then on top top of it modern medicine
has created some medications that we
actually need to treat certain
conditions that also weaken our immune
systems that allow for opportunistic
infections puppets with poisoned mines
permanently fixed on one unifying goal
to spread the infection to every last
human alive by any means necessary and
there are no treatments for this no
preventatives no cures they don't exist
it's not even possible to make them I
don't know why he says there are no
treatments for fungal infections because
they do exist so I'm sure he's making a
point that I'm just not sort of wrapping
my head around but we do have
medications for fungal infection
the one thing that I will say is
accurate about this is they show the
bite here then they show little red
bumps far away these are called
satellite lesions and those are sort of
part of what we see on a fungal
infection of skin so that is realistic
this is where we see her immunity
the question is though how is she immune
is it her blood type is it previous
exposure some medication that she got
they have no idea
well this is Ellie being born we fast
forwarded quite a bit here this scene
also didn't happen in the game which is
unique they kind of added a prequel of
what happened before kind of giving us
some insight potentially as to how Ellie
is immune so you have a pregnant mom
delivering a baby
by herself in a really dirty non-sterile
environment wow
fungi infected zombies are running
around
oh brutal fight sequence here you're
also fighting for the baby we see that
the mama bear gave birth to Ellie while
fighting probably from bearing down
during a contraction you also see
simultaneously that Mama Bear here has
been bitten by said infected zombie and
mom is still connected via the umbilical
cord to Ellie therefore potentially
spreading a small amount of particles of
this infection to the baby she cuts it
rather quickly but there is a
possibility that Ellie was just slightly
exposed to this type of fungal infection
so if you have a mild small exposure of
fungi that can't hurt you maybe you
could build up an adaptive immunity to
said fungi not proven yet but it's a
theory now we gotta fact check the
actual medicine that we're seeing in the
show I'm exhausted God damn it back in
bed I promise you I'm gonna day up why
because this is my last day what he's
talking about here is basically Medical
Aid and dying for example in New Jersey
where I work we have programs that after
meeting all the requirements making sure
that you've met with the proper mental
health folks that you've been judged by
doctors to make sure that you actually
have a short lifespan and that your
condition is irreversible that you can
receive Medical Aid and dying it's part
of Compassionate Care and end-of-life
Care Frank looks like he probably has Ms
maybe ALS also known as Lou Gehrig's
Disease they're actually quite similar
neurodegenerative diseases but the
things that they attack in our nervous
system is different for example an MS
this is an autoimmune condition where
the body attacks the myelin sheets the
protective covering of the nerves in ALS
you're actually creating damage to the
neurons themselves so it's slightly
different in that sense but a lot of the
symptoms look quite similar oh this
scene here is very fascinating to me
because if Ellie believes this to be
something that she has in her blood
antibodies as an example she's
essentially trying to do like a
covalescent plasma transfusion here the
question is is she going to create a
proper transfusion kit and as we all
know given the lack of supplies and the
circumstances she's going to do the
classic Blood Brothers thing or blood
sisters thing where she's going to make
an incision and try and bleed over his
wound but as we know while that can
transmit some infections it's not going
to transfer enough healing factors for
it to be beneficial and the reason we
use covalescent plasma by the way for
these types of transfusions like we use
them with covet is because the plasma
which makes up the majority of your
blood it's that yellow portion of blood
that I've shown you in previous videos
that we desperately need donations of so
donate your plasma that's where the
antibodies float and by getting that
donation you can actually pass along
immunity to others well this is where we
learn this uh this community of people
actually involved in cannibalism
what is it
venison many people will say oh that
must carry so much disease in reality
not to sound gross human flesh is not
that much different from eating animal
flesh in terms of risk you cook it well
the person's not sick in the moment it's
very similar obviously the human body
has a weird distribution of proteins and
fats in order for it to be nutritious so
it's not very nutritious but then the
brain it can carry a disease known as
Kuru this actually was a big problem in
the 50s and 60s in New Guinea where they
actually as part of their culture would
consume the brains of other humans it's
very problematic because it's lethal and
we learned a lot about prion disease
from that scenario and specifically a
lot because the incubation period was so
long that it actually allowed us to
study it and see this develop in the
native population so that's the one part
of the body that's like a no-go just
take me to her
I can't
she's being prepped for surgery but why
is she going for surgery what do they
hope to do if they believe her blood has
healing powers what is this purpose of
the surgery study her blood first see if
that works before putting her into
surgery or doctor
he thinks that the cordyceps and Nelly
has grown with her since birth why is
she in surgery it produces a kind of
chemical messenger it makes normal
cordyceps think that she's cordyceps
it's why she's immune that makes no
sense if it makes other cordyceps think
that she's cordyceps they wouldn't bite
her he's going to remove it from her
multiply the cells in a lab produce
those chemical Messengers and then we
can give it to everyone that's probably
the worst theory of why she's immune
whoever that doctor is needs to be
relegated to the D-League the G League
where do doctors go I don't know he
thinks it could be a carriage hole
cordyceps grows inside the brain how
does he know that how does he know that
cordyceps grow inside the brain not in
the blood and then infect the brain
through chemical Messengers it does
how does she know how have they become
experts in cordyceps when I don't know
about cordyceps the only thing I know
about cordyceps is there's something to
do with caterpillars that's my knowledge
of course and some people use them
because they think it gives them like a
better athletic performance I understand
if you fail doing all the initial tests
and then this is your last thing okay
fine but they haven't even tried
sampling her blood why not take a uh
like a pint of blood from her give it to
someone who has a cordyceps infection
see if it heals them this is a actually
a great situation to talk about the
trolley problem do we sacrifice one
Ellie in order to save the human race
I'm curious leave your comments down
below because I need to know on the
hooker
how did you get in here all right so we
see the heart monitor we see good lights
we see them wearing proper protective
gear it looks like a very sterile
environment actually no
oh my God
they're taking off the EKG leads they're
pulling out the IVs that was a weird
placement for the IV it was kind of in
the middle of the forearm not
anti-cubital I will say they did create
a nice makeshift hospital I just don't
know what they were about to do what
medical procedure surgically would help
them find the Cure I actually asked all
sorts of ethical questions just like
that to chat GPT to see if it's as smart
as a real doctor
it actually was a little smarter but
also a little stupider click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
and healthy and fungi free
[Music]
foreign